Yeah, some guy called over here but doctor he's looking for a driver you interested I am NOT a medical doctor
I'm a musician. I'm about to embark on a concert to work in the deep south what other experience do you have?
Public relations
Do you foresee any issues in working for a black man you and the deep south three problems promise me?
You're gonna write me or water the friends
Some dental smell, but I've never had fried chicken at my life people love the fried chicken
You have a very narrow assessment of me. Tony Yeah, right. I'm good
We'll be interacting with some of the wealthiest people in the country. It is my feeling that your diction wolf could use some finessing
Why you break my balls because you can do better mr. Bat along
The Lord, I saw dr. Shirley play the piano it's like a genius
I think come on gotta throw enough to get grease on my blanket
Or my blankie this gentleman says that I'm not permitted to dine here. I'm afraid not
How does he smile and shake their hands like that
Because it takes courage to change people's cars
What are you doing I'm uh de Leon dear Dolores. Sometimes you remind me of a house
You know, this is pathetic, right but this time
The distance between us is breaking my spirit
Falling in love with you was the easiest thing I have ever done
Pitas kissing kids that's like clinging a cowbell at the end of Shostakovich is seven. That's good. It's perfect. Oh,
Never win with violence you only win will you maintain your dignity?
People you mr. Bigshot doing concerts for rich people, so if I'm not black enough if I'm not white enough territory, whatever my
Anyone can sound like Beethoven
Your music will you do oh you can do that
What do we do about the bones we do this
Pick it up. Tony squirrels would eat it. Anyway pick it up